rescue efforts are underway in Western
Japan after a powerful earthquake caused
widespread damage and triggered tsunami
warnings at least eight people have been
killed in and around the epicenter of
the earthquake Axel zovich
reports these are the moments a
magnitude 7.6 earthquake struck Western
Japan the ground shakes for nearly a
minute in the city of wajima near the
epicenter of ishika prefecture down
power line sparked
fires but across Japan's western coast
there was another
threat a major tsunami warning is in
effect for Noto Ishikawa prefecture we
are currently observing a large tsunami
people near the shoreline and Riverbanks
please evacuate to Higher
Ground nearly 13 years after a tunami
and the most powerful earthquake ever
recorded in Japan killed more than
20,000 people here are scared and run to
hide the whole room was shaking the TV
was shaking I had to keep um everything
um on the table uh yeah uh I do I did
felt safe in my room though but but
everything else was
shaking the impact of the Quake leaves
homes in
Ruins roads fractured and debris
scattered across
streets I've received report that very
large scale damage has been confirmed so
far including numerous human casualties
building collapses and
fires that prompted concerns about the
safety of nearby nuclear power plants
played down by Japan's nuclear
[Music]
Watchdog there are currently no reported
irregularities with nuclear power
plants but the threat is not over
seismologists are warning of possible
after shocks or another strong
earthquake and say they could happen at
any moment Axel zovich aljazera
we're joined by from Kwa by Unice Kim
from war this what's the latest
Unice yeah so we've since moved to uh a
different part of kazawa this is a
residential enclave and I'm going to
just step out of frame for our cameraman
to show you the aftermath of that
magnitude uh 6 point or sorry 7.6 Quake
although the power in this area was
probably closer to magnitude 5 but you
can see just the damage the the ground
giving way under these homes and
entangled among them are cars uh you can
see a car just squashed under a uh
dislocated home and neighbors here say
that there were people inside of these
homes uh when the ground shook but as
far as they know nobody uh have died
thankfully from this uh amazing uh scene
here uh neighbors say that gas and water
are still cut so we see uh staffers here
trying to kind of bring some semblance
of order into this residential Enclave
but they say that they have managed to
get uh power back but Ishikawa is a
coastal prefecture uh of some 1 million
people along the west of Japan's main
island of honu this is the region that
has taken much of the damage not to
mention uh Tremors and aftershocks from
that New Year's Day Quake uh and on the
north is the up and center of this Quake
Noto Peninsula and according to Japan's
public broadcaster NHK most of the known
fatalities are being confirmed in wajima
city also on the Northern tip of the
prefecture where that fire had broken
out on Monday and among the deceased are
people in their teens into their 90s but
the hardest hit Noto remains largely Out
Of Reach as a main roads that connect to
that uh horn-shaped
Peninsula remain damaged and this is
also affecting rescue efforts as you can
imagine uh communication lines have also
been impacted so while the Japanese
people are very resilient to uh
earthquakes it is also inevitable or it
is indeed a in the back of people's
minds the the possibility of strong
after Quakes uh after shocks rather uh
as as the uh weather agency here in
Japan are warning people to stay away
from the coastal areas at least for the
next week in particular in the coming
few days Unice we've only got about 30
seconds on this but I just wanted to ask
I mean the the scale of I know that
people in Japan have experienced
earthquakes before obviously but the
scale of this is significant how is the
government dealing with
this right so uh prime minister fumio
kishida said that he's heading up an
emergency Disaster Response headquarters
they're in touch with local officials
And discussing how to go about these
rescue efforts and dispatch the
self-defense forces as well as fire and
police Personnel but he admits that this
is a great Challenge and and aerial
footage from of helicopters show that
there are spots of fires and and uh
infrastructure damage as well as what he
says extremely large scale damage so
we're just beginning to see some of
those damage thank you very much indeed
yis Kim in carasa thank you